Glanville Anu lives without electricity
he has no way to store fresh meat each
day is a vital quest for food just a few
days ago I was still hunting caribou
both shots missed things have changed
and I'm not going after caribou anymore
it's getting too late in the season
there's a lot more flies out just in the
last few days and the lakes all covered
in water so I'm just gonna be
concentrating on getting smaller animals
now like porcupine duck should be coming
soon there's some squirrels around so
I'm gonna be hunting those kind of
animals down it flies out all right
that's some scraps I had to throw out
this morning when things warm up at this
time of year the flies start coming out
they go all over the meat and they lay
eggs on me the eggs hatch little maggots
ruin the meat you can't eat it
Hey look at shoot squirrels for one
reason because they chew on things
around here that cause a lot of damage
they'll chew up a tent or they'll get
into my caribou hides but I also eat
them
there is this little red squirrel I like
to eat all the different animals out
here I like to eat red squirrels once in
a while spent a couple months since I
ate one this one's pretty messed up by
shooting it you see I I'm just gonna get
the legs and it's just a little variety
squirrel legs it's a lot more than just
a flavor of the food although that's
important it's a lot more than the
nutrition of the food although I think
the nutrition of this food is
unsurpassed but it has to do with the
relationship to the food I just don't
feel the same if I go in a store and buy
some food they're got grown 2,000 miles
away processed by some company that's
got some executives getting rich up in a
and house in New York City selling it to
me I just feel a lot better eating this
food out here